en un tren que viaja hacia el este
alexander imparte un curso de primeros
auxilios
y los participantes son todos empleados
ferroviarios ucranianos en misión
humanitaria
desde el comienzo de la invasión hemos
estado evacuando a los civiles hacia el
oeste hoy vamos a ir a pop rock para
sacar a la gente y darles comida agua y
asistencia médica si la necesita
los voluntarios y los miembros de las
ong están llevando a los refugiados de
todo el donbass a la estación de tren de
pop-rock pero hoy los bombardeos han
bloqueado el acceso a algunas zonas el
tren parte con 101 refugiados a bordo
mucho menos de los habituales
alcanza morales que trajeron el mayor
número posible de personas de los
lugares a los que podían llegar
como casi todo el mundo aquí luzmila y
su madre no querían irse
como mi madre es discapacitada y se
organizó todo en casa fue muy complicado
y quién quiere irse de todos modos nadie
quiere salir de su casa toma
tenía resultó herido en una explosión
en bicicleta cuando un mortero cayó
cerca
y un mes después su casa fue atacada los
voluntarios le convencieron de que se
fuera
nunca he visto un minibús ir tan rápido
eso es porque hubo disparos a lo largo
de nuestra ruta y no cualquier fuego
fuego de artillería
más adelante alexander se reencuentra
con una familia de su ciudad natal back
moto se ha vuelto mucho más intenso los
combates de 2014 fueron un juego de
niños comparados con esto
he oído que los rusos querían tomar
ucrania en tres días bueno es un
completo fracaso
vamos a ganar esta es la continuación de
las guerras de independencia que
libraron nuestros antepasados y
llegaremos hasta el final estamos unidos
saldremos victoriosos gracias
los padres de alexandr siguen en back
moore uno de los principales objetivos
de los rusos todavía no han conseguido
convencerles de que evacúen